welcome to the science Asylum I Nick
lucid in the centrifugal force video we
got to see how weird things look and
feel when you're rotating but the
weirdness doesn't stop there
centrifugal force is not the only force
that seems to appear when you're
rotating there's this other one you may
have heard of it's called the Coriolis
force or sometimes the Coriolis effect
that's the thing that tells you which
way your toilet flushes right no toilets
are way too small for that Milton roll
the footage no no no I don't care if
you're in the middle of something roll
it these are two toilets in Michigan
flushing in opposite directions
myth busted now it is true that the
rotation of the earth causes a Coriolis
effect it's just not strong enough to
affect something as small as a toilet
which are influenced far more by
imperfections in the toilet bowl how
level the floor is and how the water is
released from the toilet tank yes those
are monkeys on my shower curtain got a
problem with that
however if we're dealing with something
really big with motion that spans over
at least today then we'd have to worry
about it in the Detroit Science Center
they have something called a Foucault
pendulum this pendulum is so big that it
hangs from the top floor down to the
basement floor since it's so big and
heavy
it's basically unaffected by all those
small scale influences like the air or
friction standing on the earth it
appears that the direction of the swing
changes throughout the day and how much
time the cycle takes depends on your
latitude here at 42 degrees north
it takes about 36 hours to go all the
way around sometimes science centers
will put clocks underneath them Google
even had one in the Google Doodle on
September 18 2013 if you're able to step
off the earth though you'll just see the
rotation of the earth exerting a torque
on the pendulum bigger oh yeah
hurricanes hurricanes also called
tropical cyclones are so big you can see
them from space in the northern
hemisphere they always rotate
counterclockwise
in the southern hemisphere they always
rotate clockwise in fact it's such a
major part of how hurricanes work they
can't even cross the equator this
graphic from NASA shows the paths taken
by all the Hurricanes from 1985 to 2005
notice the gap at the equator if you
zoom in you can actually see some of
them approach the equator and veer off
along it like it's a wall we can also
make the Coriolis force more significant
by returning to our friend the
merry-go-round since it rotates faster
than once a day we should notice the
weirdness let's say I'm on the
merry-go-round and I decide to throw a
ball if you're watching from the ground
then the ball appears to basically
travel straight once released it's only
being pulled to the ground by gravity
which is exactly what you'd expect for
something without any other forces on it
but that's not what I see to anyone on
the merry-go-round things look really
weird
see the ball veer off to one side it
looks like there's some other weird
force on it that force is the Coriolis
force and it's fictitious it's an
illusion the Coriolis force is
determined by the mass of the ball the
rotational speed of the merry-go-round
and the motion of the ball in other
words it only acts on moving objects and
only when you're taking measurements
from the rotating perspective these
things are the coolest so much science
so why don't we just always look from
the outside and forget this whole
Coriolis thing that's a good idea and in
the centrifugal force video I did say if
at all possible you should try to work
from a perspective with no acceleration
at all unfortunately sometimes that's
really inconvenient or nearly impossible
when you're trying to be practical
though sometimes it's easier just to
pretend like it's there and get through
the work just don't ever forget you're
pretending so which way does your toilet
flush let us know in the comments along
with where you live whoa whoa nothing
specific just like northern or southern
hemisphere and until next time remember
it's okay to be a little crazy
[Music]
[Music]
you